TURNOVER AND CHANCE AT SHOT.E MN
A FLAT PASS, NOT RIGHT PLAY.
TURNED O OS SPOKEN TO ABOUT
UF
OH, IT WENT OFF TH
EASY.
>> Brendan: JOHANSSON DRAGS ANE.
LONE ALL-STAR IN THIS INAUGURAL
SEASON FOR EKHOLM.
MASON APPLETON, SELECTION FROM
WINNIPEG.
AND THIS
WASN'T THE PLAY BUT THE HACK ON
THE HANDS ON THE WAY BY.
>> D GOALS.
>> Jennifer: NICE ENTRSI TO THE
DUCHENE AN TAPE.
SAROS DIDN'T COME OUT AND PLAY
WITH TS AWAY FROS APPLETON, THE
SCORE!
YANNI GOURDE!
THREE QUICK ONES FORO RIGHT-HAN.
HE'S ON HIS STRONG SIDE.
YANNI GOURDE, STAYS ONSISI PLAY
PUCK IN DEEP.
>> Brendan: :
SITUATION YOU CAN GET IN ON THE
HUNT HERE.
FIRST MAN IN, TOLVANEN IARDS.
JOSI IN STRIDE.
ROMAN JOSI, .
FORSBERG STRIPPED BY YANNI
NASHVILLE.
ONE, TWO, THREE WHACKS AT IT,
NOBODY SOFT SPOT.
PASS DEFLECTED AWA OFFSIDE.
>> Darren: HE'.
>> Darren: THAT'S A GREAT FLIP
THERE.
>> BrendndME BACK,
WENNBERG FOR SEATTLE, EXAMPLPLD
SHORTHANDED GOALALPUCK, PASS TOT
OF THE ZON